thank you guys for talking to me about
this this show is completely wild in the
best way
i
appreciate you making me sit there and
go oh my god what is happening more
times than anything i've ever watched
you're welcome
when this project came your way what got
you most excited about it and what were
you most scared or nervous about
i think that
we live in an age where there's just so
much content there's just there's so
many things to binge and you know we've
gotten really
used to just throwing something on and
then scrolling through our phone and
when i read these brilliant scripts by
nick and tosca and lenore zion
um you know these minds i just said this
is something that you cannot
you will not even if you whether you
vibe with it or not whether it's your
cup of
kitten blood or not uh you're not going
to scroll through your phone on it you
there's just it is
the audience will be captive no matter
what and that was important to me i
wanted to make something that cuts
through all of that uh it was exciting i
am a huge horror fan
i'm a huge fan of their their work
already uh so it was it was a no-brainer
for me and i liked the character i like
the fact that she
is um fallible i like the fact that she
is dynamic in this other way that it's
not just like strong woman you know she
makes big mistakes and i wanted to see
that i wanted to see a character like
this
also i mean
i
i wanted to work with catherine again
this is our second time together and
catherine is just my she's my boro baby
that's my borrow
and what i loved about it was that
it was sort of uh
i don't know
what was happening before the history of
these these characters
i was told every day because i kind of
had lost track
but
i kind of loved that it was i mean
obviously it has a lot to do with what
when women go through
societally and you know the system
but
uh lisa nova was sort of what did you
say about that
it wasn't you uh wait how did you put it
you [ __ ] with the
wait you [ __ ] with the wrong filmmaker
instead of the wrong woman you know like
it made it sort of
we wanted to transcend that
yeah we want i mean it was about sort of
the work and the art and like [ __ ] you
in my personal life you know
um
but and i i did appreciate that even
though um
you know i've done a lot of sort of
i've done things where i always feel
for um
i'm always against the sexism and i'm
always against the whatever but this was
i don't know it was kind of
cool that it was about art mostly
and
and
the the vengeance of people in power
and how we want to avenge our souls too
you know
in a way i look at acting like
free-falling you know someone just like
gives you a shove off of a very tall
building and you really have no
control and that's what it's like
inviting a character in for me you know
you you just sort of go okay
inhabit this vehicle it's sort of like a
borough
like this person jumps into your body
and
you get lost and so
that was
terrifying for me the entire time
yeah we didn't know what the hell was
going on
i mean he did because she is insanely
this woman
um
came
ready to go every single day and just
ran away with it and it was kind of just
keeping up really it's incredible to
watch
[Music]
nervous about setting everything on
fires really
but with catherine there i think
yeah yeah yeah it was very helpful to
help so what what else do you have to
add
no i i mean katherine for you when we
first meet bora she doesn't have the
surface qualities that we traditionally
associate with power in our society
she's soft-spoken she's this
woman with wild hair and smudge lipstick
and she's carrying a cat which you know
sort of
allows us to see that crazy cat lady
trope
because of your performance we never
doubt her power
so what is the secret to playing
internal power rather than external
power because it really comes through in
this
oh thank you appreciate that it's the
secret is if if people imbue you with
that part of it is in the writing
and
um
support i mean you can't do it without a
director you can't do it without your
cast you can't and a lot of it is just
sort of telling you
rosa
you know
telling me that i have the power
uh i don't know if that answers your
question but um
i think it's that cleaner magic
i've met a few keeners now and i and
they're all very powerful
people
you know i don't know kind of trying to
stay present and loving nature and stuff
for real
rosa for you your character's acceptance
of every outrageous moment is so vital
in keeping the audience grounded through
all of these wild twists and turns
but you also have to react in a way that
feels genuine rather than just blase
about it so how did you find a balance
of staying authentic while honoring
lisa's ability to just sort of accept
the nightmare logic of anything that
comes her way
well it just sounds like my real life
don't you do that on a regular basis
christina
do you react to things authentically uh
even though they're bonkers insane i
mean we accepted a lot of things in 2020
that i think uh and we took it on the
chin and we took it um
uh while reacting authentically so i
just i just tried my best to
to do that to like catherine is saying
to be present to be authentic but the
main thing that always pulled me back
was
with lisa's what is the focus here the
focus is always her art
the focus is always the art so any
reaction anything that happens you know
is sort of accepted because it's like
well i'm on the way to make my movie
okay so i'm making you i'm i'm gonna
place a curse on someone okay so there
are zombies over there that's fine maybe
i'll use them in my movie you know it's
always
all it always comes back to the art and
that's what was so great about playing
lisa's because that she is almost to a
myopic degree so laser focused on making
this film
and knows that she can
and so everything extraordinary that
happens
uh you know she reacts to it because how
could you not these things are really
happening to you these things are
extraordinary but
they're not more extraordinary than the
dream and i think that as an actor
myself
uh as an artist myself wanting to be
you know
in this place that i am now working with
catherine keener
there were many things in my actual life
that i had to go like ah but okay you
know real-life vampires uh real-life
predators um you know
yeah it's true just to um kind of go off
of what you said rosa it's interesting
because um
it all often on a set you don't do it
intentionally but
somehow you start inhabiting the
character and it starts you know you
kind of start acting
nuts if the characters like that it just
really mirrors it and i would
borrow was the same way as lisa they
both had their
i wasn't really interested in helping
you i wanted to i needed to get
something from you you fascinated me
but um you know i had my own thing i had
my
own objective
so
katherine when i spoke with nick antosca
he told me that boro wasn't really
inspired by any particular real world
occult or mythology but more of a
hodgepodge of many influences
so what inspirations influences
references did you turn to in creating a
backstory and understanding her and
figuring out how you wanted to live in
that
well the mythology that they provided me
with was um you know it was kind of um
you know
it's wide open for you so
bad dreams um
i looked at photos of i was i did i tell
you i thought it was like a mashup for
me it was sort of yoko ono and jimi
hendrix if they got together i mean if
they'd combined and um
i don't know i was just i
i found it it was
very kind of psychedelic in a way that
you and that you kind of the challenge
was to expand your mind but also as a fi
like a six year old where there are no
limits you know if you're gonna be
you're gonna play darth vader and
something like you go no one can break
it um even though and it was it was just
fun i mean we talked about that it's
play and that it's
you know play is limitless
so
uh but
to be honest they did fill me in a lot
not that it really counted but they
they freed me up a lot to just do they
were so accepting sometimes i just
thought i don't know what the hell is
going on here i i really don't know
and um
for real right yeah it was a wild ride
and you know you shoot everything out of
the sequence too it's like
it's a it was a wild ride to shoot it
yeah and i would say to rosa is this is
this wrong
is it just completely [ __ ] up i don't
know
because you want to stay true to the
character and represent
in any way evil
good blah blah and all all of us in
between um
you want to you want to do it justice
but
these these people were people people i
really know
so that's where the mythology came in
characters
historical or literary characters who
i've i i've
come to sort of love
you know they help
for sure well rosa this is billed as a
limited series and lisa's story feels
satisfying and resolved but from a
character standpoint what do you think
her new goals are for the future as she
walks away from this i mean what is her
head's face in those final moments of
the season
[Laughter]
um well you know la is is a is a
is a black magic town uh it can be and
um it's filled with predators and
vampires i think we just
showcase them
you know those things
in a heightened way but i think that
town
can really chew you up and spit you out
uh so i think by the end she's like you
know what i have some internal
investigation to do i'm gonna go home
i'm going to find my mom and um but i
don't think she ever
ever stops making art i think i think
she goes to brazil and makes a movie
there
to be frank with you
sorry
um she actually her father leads
ayahuasca ceremonies so
we talked a lot about that and a lot
about brazil she's brazilian
um so
yeah i think she does go and do
ayahuasca and i think she makes an
another movie there i think that
la is just um
you know this is just an allegory for
how uh vicious it can be
what does the title of the show mean to
each of you guys does it have
a special meaning or do you like that
people seem to not be quite sure of the
meaning of the title
i love it first of all it's it's the
name of the of the ip it's the name of
the book um
for me it was like someone who just
steps off the bus and it's this brand
new here comes this brand new cherry
flavor
um but it is also um
it's also just very vague and i really
like that too i don't even want to
prescribe
you know
any kind of answer like open for
interpretation
i have no idea
i really have no idea except you know i
saw her lips and they were looked like
cherry and so
i thought um i don't really know
i
i really don't know i i've never
asked and i've never been told i
apologize
to the author of the book because um
i'm sorry
i feel like it's okay
i believe it's the line that loose says
in the in in the book you know it's like
you are this
you are you know because in la they're
always looking for the next big thing
and the next auteur and like
you are this brand new cherry flavor um
so that's essentially where it comes
from but uh
i like them i like that it's open for
interpretation and people are like what
does it mean because it's also it fits
so well
and it doesn't really need to
have an
explanation
it's just it it does fit the the
the the series really well it does
because look at her too
thanks both you guys your rock stars i
met respect for everything you do in
this so thank you thank you so much